you
hi everyone is Jerry on August 23 2014
Hikaru Nakamura played a four game match
versus the world's top chess engine
stockfish in game 1 Nakamura was allowed
to consult with an older version of
Rybka each of these four games had time
controls 45 minutes with a 30-second
increment and it took approximately 11
hours in total for all four games this
is again game one and for the most part
I'll simply be showing the moves of the
game and providing some very brief
comments along the way so team white
again played by nakamura and Rybka
opening with e4 stockfish replying with
French defense d-4d 592 enters the
tirage open variation c5 Knight f3
Knight f6 the e pawns are exchanged and
with this current centre we can
eventually anticipate an isolated pawn
structure but first the light square
bishop scum off and white castles and
now d take C Knight take C so it is
black who has the isolated pawn in black
who will not be so quick to make
exchanges trying to keep some dynamic
possibilities in the position keep more
pieces on the board the fewer the pieces
the more accessible or more of a
weakness this isolated pawn would be so
white of course will welcome exchanges
Knight b3 does just that as well as
controls d4 not wanting to allow that
pawn to enter the white camp so easily
black avoids the exchange gets the
knight to a better post knight on F to
d4 allows this f3 advance to kick the
knight out of the white position black
castles Knight f5 is going now for the
bishop white gets just that following up
with Bishop e3 rook on a to c8 this pawn
keep in mind
is immune from capture so good move of
course placing the rook on a half-open
file if Bishop takes pawn there's b6 and
the bishop is dead
so Bishop d4 a little regrouping on the
black side half-opened file for white
and out b6 I like this b6 move there's a
couple ways you could be addressing the
pressure against a7 one might think to
simply move it but notice a difference
here with b6 what is this doing exactly
as controlling c5 and why is that maybe
important well keep in mind black is not
necessarily so quick to exchanges after
f3 Knight C 5 at this point basically
saying if you're going to take my knight
if we're going to trade pieces we're
going to black is going to have the
option to change the structure and take
over control of d4 and maybe one day
push ok so we're not going to have that
white will not take on c5 with a pair of
rooks come off Queen d2 black goes for
another exchange and eventually
repositions this Knight to a very strong
square in the position namely e6
which puts pressure on d4 and this is
maybe making possible an eventual d4
break
okay so 9 c5 it is the bishop backs up
pressure on d5 96
if white grabs on d5 the rook can grab
on c2 so c3
the queen is now free to move elsewhere
how long are having to defend c2 this is
now a very real threat
it's defended white expands this is a
perfectly healthy structure on the white
side note there's nothing that black can
target in that of the white pawns h6
allows the flight square for the King
eventually we have the Queen's coming
off this up until this point it's pretty
much been only a slight advantage for
white but nothing significant black
pawns get rolling a bit on the Kings
side grabbing some space
we now have a structural change really
the only structural change that you
could try to maybe go for on the white
side exploiting this pin for the moment
on the D file eventually white is having
now a past C pawn but black is of course
there with their own past pawn the d4
pawn rook d6 white defends black is
returning back just in case this pawn
tries to run towards the c8 square ro K
3 we have the a and B pawns exchanged
rook c8 defends the past pawn but black
is of course they are reminding white
that they also have a passed pawn the
White King is there just in time to
defend now the black rook is very active
hitting the bishop and a couple pawns on
the second rank b pawns are exchanged
the jeep on is gone and so too is the H
pawn so these pawns are all split will
be enough of an advantage as it turns
out in this one too many exchanges end
up happening at the end white is the
side who's actually up upon but it's
simply not going to be enough since this
knight can always exchange itself off
for this remaining pawn the remaining F
pawn so this one finishes up after f4
black and of course just capture I'm not
quite sure why there wasn't Knight takes
pawn here but after king f5 Bishop d2 it
is at this point that the game was
agreed to a drop so not a bad result of
course to start this match first game
ending in a draw and feel free to check
out game 2 of provide an annotation link
at the end of this video to game 2 where
Nakamura has black with yet again the
use of an older version of Rybka so
that's all for now take care bye so
stockfish opens with d4 Nakamura / Rivka
like Knight f6 we see a King's Indian
and this one and I believe black gets
exactly what they wanted out of the
opening in particular